sarah do you have disagreements with lee
on the number of aliens that are out
there so and actually yeah well and what
they look like so any of the things
we've been talking about is their um
nuanced oh it's always nice to discover
uh wisdom
through nuance
disagreement yeah i i don't i don't
wholly disagree but i think um but i do
think i disagree it's kind of there's
nuance there um but but you can disagree
no it's fine um
it is nuanced right so you made the
point earlier that you think um
you know once we discover what alien
like what life is we'll see alien life
everywhere
and i think i agree on some levels in
the sense that i think the physics that
governs us is universal but i i don't
know how far i would go to say to say
that we're a likely phenomenon because
we don't understand
all of the features
of the transition at the original life
which which we would just say in
assembly as you go from uh the no memory
physics to
uh
there's like a critical transition
around the assembly index where
assembliness starts to increase and
that's what we call the evolution of the
biosphere and complexification of the
biosphere
so there's a principle of increasing
assembliness or that goes back to what i
was saying at the very beginning about
the physics of the possible that the
universe basically gets in this mode of
trying to make
as much possibilities as possible
now
how often that transition happens
that you get the kind of cascading
effect that we get in our biosphere i
think we don't know if we did we would
know the likelihood of life in the
universe and a lot of people want to say
life is common but i don't think that we
can say that yet so we have the
empirical data which i think you would
agree with but then there's this other
kind of
uh thought experiment i have which i i
don't like um but i did have it um which
is um
you know if life emerges on one planet
and you get this real high density of
things that can exist on that planet is
it sort of dominating the density of
creation that the universe can actually
generate so like if you're thinking
about counting entropy right like the
universe has a certain amount of stuff
in it and then you know
assembly is kind of like an entropic
principle it's not entropy but the idea
is that now transformations among stuff
or the actual physical histories of
things now become things that you have
to count as far as
saying that these things exist and we're
increasing the number of things that
exist
and uh and if you think about that
cosmologically maybe earth is sucking up
all the life potential of the whole
universe i don't know but how's that can
you explain that a little bit why can
any one geographical region
suck up the creative capacity of the
universe um just like no i i know it's a
ridiculous thought i don't i don't
actually agree with it but it was just
the thought i love that you can have
thoughts
that you don't like and don't agree with
but you have to think through them
anyway yeah the human mind is
fascinating yeah i i think these sort of
um
like counter factual thought experiments
are really good when you're trying to
build new theories because you have to
think through all the consequences and
there are people that want to try to
account for say the degrees of freedom
on our planet in cosmological
inventories of you know talking about
the entropy of the universe and you know
and when we're thinking about like
cosmological arrow of time and things
like that now i think those are pretty
superficial proposals as they stand now
but assembly would give you a way of
counting it and then the question is if
there's a certain maximal capacity of
the universe's speed of generating stuff
which lee always has this argument that
assembly is about time the universe is
generating more states really what it's
generating is more
assembly possibilities and then dark
energy might be one manifestation of
that that the universe is accelerating
its expansion because that makes more
physical space and what's happening on
our planet is it's accelerating in the
expansion of possible things that exist
and maybe the universe just has a
maximal rate of what it can do to
generate things and then if if there is
a maximal rate maybe only a certain
number of planets can actually do that
or there's a trade-off about the
pace of growth on certain planets versus
others i have a million questions there
would you have do you have thoughts on
just a quick yeah i'll just say
something very quick
no it's good i think i get it i think i
get it so um all i want to say is
when i mean aliens are everywhere i mean
memories are the prerequisite for
aliens via selection and then
concentration of selection when
selection becomes autonomous so what i
would love to do is to build say a
magical telescope that was a memory
that's a magical one yeah
or a real one there would be a memory
detector to see selection so you could
you could get to exoplanets and say that
exoplanet looks like there's lots of
selection going on there maybe there's
evolution and maybe there's going to be
life so what i'm trying to say is narrow
down the regions of space we say there's
definitely evidence of memory as high
assembly there or not the high assembly
because that would be life but if select
this where where it's capable of
happening and then we've then that would
also help us frame the search for aliens
i don't know how likely it is to make
the transition to cells and all the
other things i think you're right but i
think that is
yeah we just need to get more data well
i didn't like the thought experiment
because i don't like the idea that if
the universe has a maximal limit on the
amount it can generate per unit time
that our existence is actually
precluding the existence of other things
i'll just say one thing but i think
that's probably true anyway because the
resource limitations so i don't like
your thought experiment because i think
it's wrong because well no no no i do
like the thought spread so what you're
trying to say is like there is a chain
of events that goes back that's
manifestly
collimated with life on earth
and you're not saying that life isn't
possible elsewhere say that there has
been these number of things contingent
things that have happened that have
allowed life to merge here
um that doesn't mean that life can't
emerge elsewhere but you're saying that
these the intersection of events may
have may be concentrated here right
um and i think that's not exact not
exactly it's more like um
like uh you know if you you look at say
the causal graphs are fundamental maybe
space is an emergent property which is
consistent with some proposals in
quantum gravity but also how we talk
about things in assembly theory then the
universe is causal graphs generating
more structure and plausible graphs
right so this is how the universe is
unfolding and maybe there's a
cap on the rate of generation like the
there's only so much stuff that gets
made per
update of the universe and then if
there's a lot of stuff being made in a
particular region that happens to look
the same locally spatially that's an
after effect
of the fact that the whole causal graph
is updating
you